let's start right off biden goes full
sharpton that's the focus of tonight's
angle
it was horrible to see as you saw to see
people treat it like they did horses
barely running them over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences so much for
biden tacking to the middle to unite the
country and save his presidency we
suggested that last night
well the amiable old man who ran for
president with a pledge to bring us all
together has decided that moving hard
left is his only option
and we know what the hard left thinks of
law enforcement whether it's cops on the
beat or a dangerous urban area getting
overrun by criminals border patrol in
texas trying to deter crossings by
illegal immigrants
the radicals running the democrat party
will cry racism whenever they believe it
helps them politically the facts just
don't matter
and just as they did with nick sandman
in that case remember staring at the
indige indigenous man years ago the left
is seizing on an image one image to make
unfounded defamatory claims
it's incredibly stupid which is why
kamala harris was happy to join in
i was outraged by it i it was horrible
and and
deeply troubling there's been now an
investigation that is being conducted
which i fully support and there needs to
be consequence and accountability uh the
human being should not be treated that
way
she's talking about the people on
horseback
and then she talks about consequences
and accountability
now that's hilarious coming from an
administration that still hasn't fired
anyone no accountability there for 13 of
our troops being slaughtered at the
kabul airport
or after that botched retaliatory drone
strike that killed 10 7 innocent kids
and you know what's horrible and deeply
troubling madam vice president
is that we now have an administration
run by people who have nothing but
disdain for the hard-working men and
women who put their lives on the line
every single day to keep us safe
this is disgusting
it also evoked images of some of the
worst moments of our history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery
there's that weird laugh again
is she not aware of the fact that native
americans rode on horseback themselves
in hostile situations or did she miss
that part of history
again biden and harris never speak in
this manner and this kind of very
aggressive tone about china which is
actually committing genocide
they never speak about illegal aliens or
refugees who commit unspeakable crimes
with such condemnatory tones
it's not an exaggeration to say that the
biden administration now speaks more
charitably about the taliban than it
does about u.s law enforcement
and by the way
they can all stop pretending now to care
about the american working class they
don't even wait for an investigation
they just spew poisonous rhetoric about
lying border patrol officers who are
overwhelmingly hispanic by the way
and they're paid annually only a
fraction of what hunter pockets from one
lousy painting
yet by mimicking al sharpton on race
joe and kamala just make themselves look
more petty and less serious
it's all one big change the subject move
on their part
from the images of migrant squalor and
del rio to the images of slave trader
border agents on horseback
well the truth is biden is to blame
himself for both images which is why his
poll numbers are in free fall
and he's violating not just his unity
promise but his i'll follow the science
promise as well
his cdc panel overwhelmingly rejected
recommending vaccine boosters for all
but older americans but joe doesn't care
i've made clear all along
the decision of which booster shot to
give
when to start the shot
and who will get them is left to the
scientists and the doctors
that's what happened here we bought
enough booster shots and states and
pharmacies doctors offices and community
health centers have been preparing to
get shots in arms booster shots and arms
for a while
now the panel voted 16-2 they were
overridden thank you very much
so whatever fauchy and pfizer want in
other words fauci and pfizer is going to
get this administration and that extends
to pressuring the 25 percent of adults
who've declined the vaccine for whatever
reason
biden thinks he can insult his way to
persuasiveness and popularity
three-quarters of the eligible have
gotten at least one shot
but one quarter has not gotten any and
they are causing a lot of damage
the unvaccinated overcrowd are hospitals
overrunning emergency rooms and
intensive care units
you're causing damage and funny
how you're not worried about millions of
migrants taking up hospital beds using
our resources which they do all the time
and most of them are obviously not
vaccinated mr president and they're
still being shipped all over the united
states to seed the rest of the country
with covent
so spare me the supposed concern about
spreading disease and using up hospital
resources
oh by the way and where's all the
concern about social distancing here
who really believes that only 18 to 20
of these migrants are testing positive
for covid
we're lucky at this point we can find
anyone who still wants to work in border
patrol given this nightmarish and
dangerous situation
you know i was thinking today the lies
oftentimes come so fast from biden that
sometimes it's just hard to keep up and
i'm a fast typer when i'm watching this
stuff
and if we had an honest independent fact
checker out there the biden
speechwriting shop would get crucified
for this one
take a look at what i inherited when i
came into office we had four million
people vaccinated we had no plan we had
i mean i could go down the list
so uh you know
part of it is
dealing with the panoply of things that
will land it on my plate i'm not
complaining it's just a reality
it depends on what the meaning of the
word reality is
joe's reality tracks
with one you know your typical memory
care patient's reality but on planet
earth when joe took office we were
already administering over 1.5 million
doses a day nearly 19 million people had
already received the first dose by then
in other words president trump handed
biden an incredible vaccine rollout all
biden had to do was execute it
so any vaccine failures at this point
are all on jail
not only though is biden going full
sharpton on race and lying about covid
he's going full squad on not just the
rich but pretty much anyone with a small
bank account
if you file with a w-2 form
you know the
the irs has access to your bank account
and your bank tells you how much you
made what you have in there and that's
why we have to rehire some irs agents
and not to do anything not to try to
make people pay something they don't
know just say hey step up
step up and pay like everybody else does
look
i really mean this i just think it's
about just paying your fair share for
lord's sake
what a complete scam
now we know a key part of joe's jobs
plan is to grow the number of irs agents
so they can harass hardworking americans
good on you
does that mean reverend al by the way
will finally pay up
okay it wasn't a big deal it was only
4.7 million dollars in back taxes come
on
from the border to boosters to bank
surveillance we see biden's team
grabbing at any leftist cause that
presents itself
but this will only guarantee one outcome
a declining presidency and sadly for us
a declining america and that's the angle